he said that philosophers of old time
they were interested in two things one
is
the natural world the natural philosophy
and secondly wisdom the wisdom was that
you live what you believe
and therefore you are a shining role
model of what we believe
and then he goes on to say that today is
scientists about that
they are no different from a lawyer or a
banker or any anybody else as far as
their own wisdom is concerned or their
own belief
you know
in practicing what they truly believe
and I think there's a lot of Truth to
that and I think that's a Pity that I
think it should be it should be much
nicer if in fact what was in more people
were interested in both aspects of this
world
and so I think this was where was this
this was um
in the early 80s I think
um
I felt that I always been interested in
the interview whatever it is maybe
because I was born in India it's not
that my family was very spiritual or
traditional something I don't know but I
read some things you know I also read a
lot
or
scientific things many more than the
internal World things but still there
might have been some atmosphere or
whatever it is I've been interested for
a long time so in about 80 sometime in
the 80s I sort of felt that you know
this really is
I mean the point was that
there seems to be such a
such a Schism between the two things and
when I listen to scientists for example
one thing that I like about science
scientists very much compared to the
people experts in the internal world is
that one doesn't think one has the I
mean if you're not yes okay you have
everything in this in the physics world
that everything is going to be explained
tomorrow
then people don't think that there is
absolute
true
and that is just around the corner or
that some people know it or some people
have already arrived is that the
absolute truth
I mean with my great I mean admiration
is the wrong word but yes
oh for Einstein and so on and no
hesitation saying that Einstein was just
wrong about many things
that the idea of the Big Bang is
completely repulsive to him
you just watched a clip from the
theories of everything channel for the
full video and all its magnificence then
click here and if you'd like to see more
then subscribe enjoy